قبل بدء القمه تذكرت المدينه ماساتها
القديمه فهذا المبنى هو الوحيد الذي صمد
في وجه القنبله الذريه التي القيت على
هيروشيما قبل نحو 80 عاما
حرصه اليابان على ان يزوره القاده قبل
انطلاق اجتماعهم وبينهم للمفارقه رئيس
الولايات المتحده البلد المسؤول عن القاء
هذه القنبله
رمزيه المكان لا تخفى في سياق دولي عاد
فيه الخطر النووي الى الواجهه
اختياره هيروشيما ليس مصادفه فبمجرد نطق
كلمه هيروشيما يذكر بالقصف النووي وهذا
يحمل عنوانا لهذه القمه مفاده ان القاده
المشاركين هنا هم ضد استخدام السلاح
النووي
وذاك ما قيل تصريحا قبل القمه و خلالها
فالقاده اعلنوا انهم لا يقبلون اي تهديد
باستخدام السلاح النووي ورسالتهم في ذلك
موجهه الى روسيا التي فرضوا عليها دون
مفاجاه عقوبات جديده
يقول بيان القمه ان العقوبات الجديده تهدف
الى حرمان روسيا من التكنولوجيا التي تدعم
قدراتها العسكريه كما تروم منعها من
الالتفاف على العقوبات المفروضه عليها
سابقا واضافه قطاعات جديده اخرها تجاره
الالماس لانه
نركز الان على اغلاق الباب في وجه الثغرات
والاستمرار في قطع الامدادات الحيويه عن
روسيا سنقيد التجاره بالالماس الروسي الذي
لم يدوم الى الابد
واذا كان الاجتماع قد حقق المطلوب منه
بشان الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وقدم
المشاركون فيه تعهدا بدعمها ماليا وعسكريا
وانسانيا فالامر يبدو مختلفا بالنسبه
للعلاقه مع الصين فالرئيس الفرنسي يصل الى
القمه بعد اسابيع قليله من تحذيره مما
وصفها لسياسه التبعيه للولايات المتحده
فيما يخص الموقف من الصين وتوتر علاقاتها
مع تايوان
لكن الموقف الفرنسي هذه المره حرص على عدم
اظهار ما يمكن ان يفهم على انه خلاف بشان
الصين صحيح
انها لن تكون قمه موجهه ضد الصين لكنه شدد
في الوقت ذاته على ان مجموعه السبع ستوضح
للصين اشتراطاتها من اجل التعاون
وكعادته قمم مجموعه السبع لم تمر هذه
القمه دون احتجاجات
مناهض الراسماليه والامبرياليه خرجوا
لاعلان رفضهم للقمه ولما سيصدر عنها لكن
صوتهم وكالعاده ايضا بقي حبيس الشوارع
الخلفيه حيث حيل بينهم وبين الوصول الى
مقر القمه ما بين حرب مشتعله واخرى تنظر
بالاشتعال تنعقد هذه القمه في سياق دولي
سمته التصعيد والواضح ان التوتر لن ينتهي
قريبا فقدت السبع اجتمعوا فيه هيروشيما
لتوحيد موقفهم من روسيا ومن الصين لا
لتغييره محمد البقالي الجزيره هيروشيما